we talked yesterday about this idea of
polynomial division okay it's just like
long division for numbers except we're
dealing with polynomials so since I love
you were here yesterday for the benefit
of those who were what we'll do is
before we tuck into their new stuff
let's just do a really simple example
okay
good morning so for instance if we draw
out our our long division bar we know
how long division normally works there's
a thing that you divide there's the
thing you divide by then is your answer
and your remainder at the top okay just
like in normal numerical original with
an example what would you like to let's
let's keep it simple what we'd like to
divide by give me something monic and
linear just for the sake of it X plus 2
will do the job just fine okay give me a
hand me a cubic in here so I wanna give
me a cubic polynomial maybe to start off
with say oh I don't know X cubed that's
pretty easy
should we make it like three or
something like that okay what else we
gonna put in here maybe at minus x
squared plus 7x minus four okay so what
we're gonna do here is what we do just
like with normal long division I was
doing a term by term and it ends up
being quite long and well that's what I
call long division right but at least
it's not too complicated so morning will
begin by saying how many X's fit into
three X cubes where we're focusing on
the X's because even though there are
constants and other numbers flying
around the X's are clearly the thing
that is important here so how many X's
can I do 3 x squared and you know you
did it right because when I do the next
step which is multiply around it's going
to kids all right 3x squared times X is
3x cubed that should eliminate 3x
squared times 2x is 6x squared fantastic
ok we are awake that's always good to
know at this stage I've got to now take
away what I've created here from the
previous lobe ok so you gotta watch your
negatives because there's lots of them -
x squared take is 6x squared that's
going to be
I'm subtracting right so I think it's
minus 7x squared yes again one of the
tricky things about this being
polynomial long division is you get
negatives right when you're dividing by
numbers there are no negatives to be
seen okay
as minus 7x squared there I will bring
down this plus 7x and then I posed the
question again how many X's will fit
into this thing minus 7x right
just like in place value you count down
like thousands hundreds tens here you're
cutting down powers of X so you know
you're gonna have to get to a power of
one
I will dutifully multiply it back so I
get minus 7x squared minus 14x I'm now
subtracting again so watch out for the
double negative what will you end up
with 7x so right yeah minus negative 14x
I will bring down this negative 4 and
I'm pretty much there how many X's fit
into 7x by definition 7 plus 7 right I
go here 7x plus 14 my final subtraction
is gonna land me with yeah it's tricky
isn't it Oh what did I do
where are we looking we're looking yeah
see even right yeah there you go let's
fix that shall we 21 21 what does that
leave me with
4 42 plus 42 that's convenient
oh I'm doing the wrong line aren't I
that's that's the 4 you see how easy it
is to test yourself into it yeah nice
that's 21 and that's 42 isn't it that's
more like it
okay wonderful last subtraction let's
get it right this time
minus 40
oh yeah okay right now here's a weird
thing I don't know if this came up in
the previous example but this final
number no X's fit Internet there are no
X's in that term and there's no more
stuff to grab onto okay so that makes
this final term the remainder okay now
unlike in numerical loner vision you can
get remainders than- it's a bit funny
isn't it right you if you if you've got
a negative remainder if you divided my
numbers you'd say you've done your
division wrong okay but that's why this
is what this is now I can make a
statement out of this they call it the
division statement I can make an
equation that includes your divisor your
dividend your quotient and your
remainder four pieces okay
here's what the equation would look like
it all starts with the dividend that's
the object you were manipulating that
you were dividing by so we can say that
thing oh no I was writing the wrong
thing sorry that's the that's the
question the dividend is here just
looking at the wrong line okay so this
thing is your divisor multiplied by your
quotient except that there's the
remainder also hanging on right so here
comes the divisor X plus 2 here's your
quotient 3x squared minus 7x plus 21 but
if you go ahead and you multiply that
out you don't get the original
polynomial you get the original
polynomial with the remainder okay and
of course you can go and double check
that it's one of the nice things you
just expand it out if you are lazy you
can find something online to do you just
punch all that in and it'll expand it
out and confirm that you got what you
were supposed to get okay so this is
polynomial division in a nutshell but
sometimes you get asked questions I'm
gonna dive into this well you actually
have to put something into the dividend
or into the divisor that's not there so
here's a really quick example okay if I
asked you to divide let's give some
polynomials
let's say let's divide X cubed minus 1
by X plus 2 ok X cubed minus 1 by X plus
2 now when you have a look at this you
think ok well that's my problem I know
how to write the divisor over here and I
also know how to write only this as
simple as it can get right except for
the fact that like we do in numerical
long division if I said to you hey a
thousand and five a thousand and five
that's 1,000 and five units but there's
actually things in between that aren't
there that you're right because how do
you write a thousand and five you write
one and then you say well there are no
hundreds and there are no tens and then
there's five units right so it because
we have a place value system you have to
have things in there that indicate where
the value is zero right does that make
sense now because polynomial long
division is built on numerical long
division we end up with the same problem
over here
how many x squared terms out other there
are none so you have to say that there
or not right how many X terms are there
in the entries there are none and then
there's the minus one there's a constant
okay now you can see how this is gonna
play in just like if we were dividing
something like this by seven right if
fact is in just the same way have a look
how many X's fit into X cubed answer x
squared you multiply back and then you
realize oh when I'm doing my next steps
right it doesn't just skip all of this
stuff and then go straight to the
negative one that wouldn't make sense
because you'd have x squared terms
trying to muck around with a constant
term just like in place value you're
thousands lined up with thousands
hundreds with hundreds tens with tens et
cetera so here I've got to now do the
subtraction yes oh yeah of course it is
so here we go so I'm gonna do my
subtraction now that all case was that
this is gonna leave me with minus two x
squared and then I bring down the zero X
that's there
okay I ask this question again that's
gonna be minus 2x yeah are you with me
yeah so you can see I mean the process
is all the same right but you have to
know to be able to say oh there's
there's nothing's and the nothing's kind
of matter right what have I got here - 4
X double negative there yeah so what do
I end up with 4 X take away 1 how many
X's are in there four of them four X
plus a final light - no so that's my
remainder are you okay with that so
missing terms please take note
they're not there but when you do the
division you must say that there's
nothing there because that's obviously
part of the process you can see where
that 0x squared has to be used and that
0x also has to be used okay